[Music]
one of the number one questions we get
here on the air and by email and on our
other podcasts is how do i get my spouse
on board
and
um
number one
there's not a magic formula
for that
uh number two it is absolutely necessary
that you do
get them on board
because working a separate plan will
eventually cause you to
work a separate plan
the number of people who build wealth
and have high quality marriages
30 years into a separate plan is
approaching zero
that's your data but i think it's right
it's actual data wow i mean the ten
thousand millionaires that we
interviewed the vast majority of them
said i don't remember the number it was
in the 70 80 percentile that their
spouse and them work together
so there's a high correlation between
the ability to build wealth there's a
high correlation between high quality
communication and shared values
in them to having a high quality
marriage duh
shocker
now how do we how do we what are what's
your best shot
what's our best shot around here of
getting the spouse
to see that they need to be on board i
can't make this basket on board yeah but
i can help them see how important it is
number one data
says that you're going to have a crummy
marriage and your likelihood of building
wealth is going to suck
if you're not on the same page and
you're not working together pulling the
wagon up the hill together both of you
have a vote you know
saver versus spender free spirit versus
nerd
abundance versus scarcity and you
balance each other out and if two people
just like get married one of you is
unnecessary so it's good that opposites
attract
but how do you get the spouse to see the
need
i think the biggest uh
piece is starting with that why and
having that shared goal if you can't get
excited about the future why do you care
about your present
why does it even matter to get out of
debt if you feel like you like laying in
your own poop and so what we got to do
is find a why that gets us on fire a
little bit and what i like to do some
people get inspired by the math a lot of
people haven't even done the math on
what that payment would be like to have
back in their life what could they do
what is the interest we're currently
paying some people need a little bit of
that nerdery to go oh my gosh i'm paying
sally may 600 bucks a month no we're
getting rid of this thing so once you
combine the y and the math and then you
pair it with something like financial
peace university or you both read the
total money makeover you need to create
that shared language because then they
understand it's not just what dave said
we need to get out of debt and do the
debt snowball
it becomes a no we decided that our goal
is to change our family tree we decided
that we have bigger goals in life than
to pay sally may for the next 20 years
and once you do that things change
behavior change habits change and you
start to see some progress and then you
go oh my gosh we can do this and then
every couple that stands on the stage
they go dave our marriage is better yeah
what was the key to getting out of debt
communication the budget well the two
things that come up every time just
about yeah right there you know and they
almost always raise their income yeah
but you can't raise your income if the
one at home is whining about you working
and it's just the whole thing it work it
pulls together and
um
it bothers me when i hear someone say
hey we went through financial peace
university we went to the marriage of
money event
we did a dream date together we laid out
you know some of our why
and then the spouse still won't come to
the table that makes me think something
else is going on yeah because there's no
at that point you have the information
in front of you that a logical human
being says
uh the pride i've got that i brought the
dead in i gotta let that down and we
gotta work together it's our best shot
the uh the shame i have because i
brought in more death than she brought
in i gotta lay that down because it's
our best shot as a couple
um
and so i
uh uh
i don't know what's going on there but
something else is going on that's not in
the equation that we're hearing
that that is causing that because it's
not a simple thing of we just don't have
a shared vision yeah because if you can
get on a shared vision then you will
come back and do the practical stuff to
hit the vision
you know you'll you'll dial back in and
do the tactical do the budget together
make the the sacrificial decisions
together make the decision to sell one
of the cars or whatever it is you got to
do to get your budding gear
you'll do that stuff once you see where
you're going and it's worth the trip
yeah but you won't do it with thank god
it's friday oh god it's monday and you
won't do it with i'm a victim and you
won't do it with the little man can't
get ahead and the system's rigged and oh
my god the whining that goes on in this
culture
the the arrogance of entitlement is
unbelievable
but if you just sit out there and say
there's a thing i can go get that thing
if i'll do the steps to get that thing
then and that thing can just be
financial security financial peace yeah
and i think you're right there's there's
a theme i'm seeing here with people that
can't get on board and it's either
selfishness or shame it's either well
this is mine and that's yours and you
deal with yours and i'll deal with mine
or it's the shame where they go well
this is my debt i don't want you to have
the burden of that and there is that
pride you gotta suck up and go no we're
a team now and i didn't sign up for a
roommate i don't know about her but i
don't want to live with a roommate for
30 years i want to live with a grown
adult who decided that we do things
together as a family and i think
marriage counseling may be in order for
them to get on the same page and dig
into the root issue here because i don't
think it's just the budget and money i
think there is something more serious
going on